MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
In this section, we're going
to talk about particles
and accelerators.
And we use the Large
Electron-Positron Collider
at CERN as an example.
LEP, the Large
Electron-Positron Collider,
was a collider which was
operated in the late 1980s
up to the year 2000 at
center-of-mass energies
from 91 GeV up to 209 GeV.
These energies
were used to probe
the Z boson to produce
pairs of W boson
and also to look for the Higgs
boson, which didn't quite
work because its energy
wasn't quite sufficient.
The 27-kilometer over
a 16-mile circumference
collider is now the home of the
Large Hadron Collider at CERN.
And it's being used there to
collide protons with protons.
LEP had four experiments,
ALEPH, DELPHI, L3, and OPAL.
And I was happy to study data
from the particle as part
of my undergraduate thesis.
So this was very
good memories there.
But that's not the topic today.
So the topic today is
to find out how quickly,
how fast the particles
in the collider
are moving when we know
the center-of-mass energy.
So we know the center-of-mass
energy to be 209 GeV.
We know that the
energy in the beam
is half of that, 104.5 GeV.
So now to figure out how fast
the electrons are moving--
the electrons and
the positrons--
we can use our relativistic
total energy for the electron
or for the positron, which
is the kinetic energy
plus the rest mass of the
electron or positron, which
is M0 gamma times c square.
So with a mass of 511
KeV over c square,
and this energy
of 104.5 GeV, this
results in a gamma
factor of 200,000.
And if you do the
math, you'll find
that electrons and
positrons are almost
moving with the speed of light.
They're moving with the
speed of light [INAUDIBLE]..
A fun additional fact is
we are working right now
on proposing a even
larger collider, which
will then allow us
to efficiently go up
to energies of 350 GeV.
And that collider then will be
able to study the Higgs boson
with precision but also look
at [INAUDIBLE] production--
[INAUDIBLE] production in
these kind of colliders.
Another fun fact is
that CERN, the collider,
which is about 100
meters under the surface,
is spanning two countries,
Switzerland and France.
And so each particle,
lep, when we make the lep,
makes about 11,200
leps per second.
That means that there is
about 44,800 border crossings
for an electron and positron.
So they always constantly have
to show their passport when
they're moving around in LEP.
To look at a second example
here with a small accelerator,
we can accelerate
electrons through
an electrostatic potential
of 511 kilovolts or 0.511
megavolts.
The total energy then is,
again, the kinetic energy
plus the rest energy,
which is, in this example,
4.511 MeV plus 0.511 MeV.
And so here we find
the gamma factor of 2
and a velocity of 0.866.
So even in this smaller
electrostatic potential
of 500 kilovolts, we
find that electrons
are moving with
very high velocities
with velocities very close
to the speed of light.